Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Der Fußball hat seine Panama Papers, die Football Leaks. Was das bedeutet, was das alles noch bringen könnte und wie die ganze Sache eigentlich zustande kam, das erzählt mir Christoph Henrichs vom Spiegel. Christoph, ich grüße dich. Schön, dass du Zeit gefunden hast in dieser arbeitsreichen Phase deines Lebens.
Ja, herzlichen Dank für die Einladung. Freut mich, das erste Mal hier im Rasenfunk dabei zu sein. Es ist eine große Ehre.
Ja und dann gleich zu so einem Thema. Ich vermute, ich lehne mich nicht weit aus dem Fenster, wenn ich sage, du hast gerade eher zu viel als zu wenig zu tun.
Ja, das könnte man wohl so sagen. Wir haben letzte Woche ja das erste Heft rausgehauen, den Auftakt zu Footballleaks. Wir hatten dann am Freitagabend, als wir dann tatsächlich nur noch darauf warteten, dass auf Spiegel Online das Projekt dann auch online ging und wir dann auch auf die ersten Reaktionen warten konnten, das Gefühl, jetzt haben wir es geschafft. Jetzt haben wir den großen Aufschlag hingelegt und dann ist erstmal so ganz viel Druck von uns abgefallen und Ananenlinen und so weiter und jetzt auf einmal diese Woche merken wir, es geht ja genauso weiter, wenn nicht sogar schlimmer, weil jetzt weiß die ganze Welt von diesem Projekt und jetzt gibt es Reaktionen und jetzt passiert ganz viel, während wir auch noch weiterarbeiten und jetzt auch noch mitten in der Produktion zum neuen Heft stehen.
Und gleichzeitig sind ja zum Teil, Teile dieser Methoden sind ja auch wirklich legal. Das ist ja dann tatsächlich nur mal ein Riesenproblem, es gibt halt einfach sehr, sehr kleine Meistinseln, die sich da ein eigenes Geschäftsmodell aufgebaut haben, keine Unternehmenssteuer zu verlangen. Aber über andere kleinere Peanut-Abgaben, dann bei 10.000 Briefkastenfirmen, summiert sich das dann so wieder zusammen, dass man als British Virgin Islands zum Beispiel dann ganz gut über die Runden kommt.
Genau, und mit dem, was ich eben gesagt habe, meinte ich auch nicht nur Offshore-Geschäfte, also ganz im Gegenteil. Wir haben ja jetzt letzte Woche mit dem Spiegel eine Veröffentlichungs-Serie begonnen.
Genau, sag mal, was noch so kommen wird. Am liebsten kannst du mir jetzt natürlich das sehr detailliert sagen. Ich vermute mal, du musst da vage bleiben, aber deute mal so ein bisschen an, auf was kann man sich so bewegen.
Das habe ich quasi gerade schon, denn es wird im weiteren Verlauf darum gehen, wer an Deals partizipiert und wie das vollzogen wird und was es da für Absprachen gibt und wie Spieler zum Beispiel auch von Beratern und von Vereinen. Also wir gehen jetzt von dieser Steuergeschichte ein Stückchen weg und steigen in die Niederungen der Berater-Verträge zum Beispiel ein.
Oh, sehr interessant, da freue ich mich, dass ich gehofft bin, einiges zu wissen. Was erhofft, da musst du jetzt einfach für dich sprechen, was erhoffst du dir denn jetzt, dass sich verändert? Glaubst du tatsächlich, dass das zu großen Veränderungen führen kann im Fußball?
Was ich persönlich glaube, ist, dass in Deutschland, wahrscheinlich auch in ganz Europa, es nicht mehr lange so weitergehen kann. Vielleicht darf, vielleicht kann es weitergehen, ja, aber vielleicht darf es so nicht weitergehen. Und ich fände es mal wirklich ein sehr interessantes Gedankenexperiment, was bestimmt auch nicht nur von mir bisher gemacht wurde, mal zu überlegen, wie das im amerikanischen Profisport funktioniert. Das wären dann so heilige Kühe, die hier geschlachtet werden müssten mit der 50-1-Regel und darf jemand einen Verein, tatsächlich eine Privatperson, einen Verein übernehmen. Die Elf-Freunde hatte, glaube ich, im aktuellen Magazin da ein paar schöne Beispiele für, wenn irre Personen einen Verein übernehmen, was dann alles schiefgehen kann. Das wäre sehr schlitzam, aber es ist deutlich weniger verlogen als das, was jetzt auch in der Bundesliga passiert. Und wer da wie die Hände mit drin hat im operativen Geschäft, nur weil er der größte Geldgeber ist, nur in Anführungszeichen, natürlich, Geld ist alles in diesem Geschäft, da kann einem manchmal Angst und Bange werden. Und das wissen ja auch die Fans. Also ich als Fan von Borussia Dortmund kann natürlich wunderbare Sprüche über Gazprom oder Clemens Tönnies reißen, aber weiß genau auch, dass meine Freunde, die Blaufans sind, auch ihre Probleme haben mit diesen Geldgebern und mit den Leuten, die da Entscheidungen fällen können. Und das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel von so vielen Vereinen, wo ganz viel schief läuft und wie gesagt nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern in Europa. Das ist im Moment eine ganz ungute Entwicklung und das wird auch gebühlenartig von allen Leuten wiederholt, dass sie sich eigentlich die Romantik zurückwünschen. Das ist ein Wunschdenken, was nicht ganz erfüllt werden kann. Ich meine, früher war eh immer alles besser. Aber tatsächlich muss man wahrscheinlich das ganze System grundlegend ändern. Und da habe ich nicht das Patentrezept dafür. Aber ich glaube, früher oder später wird es so weit kommen, dass da etwas komplett geändert werden muss.
Transfarenz wäre schon mal ganz gut. In NBA, in NFL, da weiß ich, wie viele Millionen jemand bekommt. Das hängt natürlich auch mit dem Category-Cap zu tun, aber das wäre vielleicht auch gar nicht so die schlechteste Idee. Aber tatsächlich ist es ja mal ganz interessant zu wissen, dass dann auch Lavetzi der aktuell bestverdienendste Spieler der Welt ist, weil er in China irgendwie für 23 Monate, ich glaube 50 Millionen oder so, nagelmäßig nicht auf die Summe festbekommt.
56,7 Millionen.
56,7 Millionen. Ach Wahnsinn. Wenn man sich dann mal ausrechnet, wie viele 10.000 Jahre man selbst dafür arbeiten müsste, dann das finde ich ein ganz guter Bezugsrahmen tatsächlich.
Er hat ja auch vor seinem Wechsel betont, dass er andere Angebote dafür ausgeschlagen hat, weil er sich für die chinesische Kultur interessiert.
Klar, die haben ganz besonders tolle Geldzellmaschinen. Aber gut, gleichzeitig sind wir dann auch schon wieder in so einer Ecke, wo man halt sehr moralin sauer ist und bei mir ist es jetzt ehrlich gesagt kein Neid auf den, der muss in der chinesischen Liga Fußball spielen. Aber man könnte mir natürlich auch neid unterstellen. Es ist tatsächlich schwierig, dieses Thema zu transportieren, ohne immer mit der riesigen Moralkeule zu kommen oder als Neidharmel dazu stehen oder Dinge zu verharmlosen. Also schwierige Sache, schwierige Sache. Christoph, ich hab dich schon länger in Beschlag genommen, als du mir eigentlich versprochen hattest und ich weiß ja, dass Zeit gerade ein wichtiges Gut ist. Aber ich hab noch eine brennende Frage. Hast du mal in eurer Forensik-Software Rasenfunk eingegeben?
Nein, hab ich tatsächlich noch nicht. Vielleicht ist uns da die große Schweinerei entgangen.
Ach so, ne, das nicht, keine Angst. Nein, aber mich würde interessieren bei 1,9 Terabyte Daten, E-Mails und so weiter, ob irgendeiner von denen den Rasenfunk kennt.
Ailton fehlt einfach, steht auch nicht drin. Das weiß ich zumindest nicht.
Hätte ich aber an deiner Stelle auch gemacht, sehr, sehr cool. Ja, wenn du mir einen Gefallen tun kannst, dann kannst du das ja vielleicht mal machen. Gut, im spanischen Markt sind wir vielleicht noch nicht so verbreitet und das haben wir ja schon besprochen, dass da noch ein Schwerpunkt ist. Ich bin da zuversichtlich. Aber vielleicht ist ja einer von denen sogar Rasenfunk-Supporter. Dann finde ich den ganz gut. Man kann uns ja auch unterstützen.
Sag doch nochmal die Domain, wo man das machen kann.
Ich habe es mir gerade verkniffen, weil ich mir dachte, das ist jetzt ganz schön. Die Leute werden es finden, die sich dafür interessieren. Christoph, vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank, dass du dir diese Zeit genommen hast. Und wie gesagt, länger als eigentlich vereinbart. Ich sage nochmal, dass man dir auf Twitter folgen kann. Edder Henrichs.
Genau.
Man kann auch eton fehlt hören, das sollte man auch tatsächlich tun, wenn du halt dann irgendwann auch mal wieder Zeit für deinen eigenen Podcast hast.
Ja, ich glaube, ich bin jetzt auch ein bisschen verdorben für meinen Fußballpodcast. Denn mein Prinzip mit meinem Kollegen Matthias, wenn wir uns vor dem Mikro gesetzt haben, dann haben wir uns einfach über Fußball unterhalten, wie wenn wir uns in der Kneipe treffen und um Fußball quatschen. Und da sind auch gerne dann mal ein paar Halbwahrheiten oder eine Menge Blödsinn auch mit dabei. Und jetzt ist man auch bei einigen beäutert, wenn man hier die Fakten kennt. Aber Ailton Field einfach wird es auch in Zukunft in irgendeiner Form irgendwann wieder geben.
Ja, das ist schön und wir werden einfach alle damit umgehen müssen, wie sich der Fußball gerade verändert. Alle Fußballfans da draußen. Christoph, vielen herzlichen Dank noch mal. Ed der Henrichs bei Twitter. Mein Name ist Maxer Kuopost. Ed Genetzer bei Twitter. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, liebe Zuhörer. Und Glückwunsch an Raphael Buschmann. Vielleicht hört er das ja irgendwie. Ed Raffanelli. Toller Leak. Ich bin gespannt, wie oft wir das im Rasenfunk noch thematisieren dürfen. Wenn es nach mir geht, sehr häufig. Christoph, vielen, vielen Dank dir.
Wir geben uns Mühe. Danke schön.